okay we can relax with pep and then add
a little Jeff garlic to curb the
enthusiasm of the Lowery's mmm hello sir
yeah how are you dad I'm just at the
house going over some business stuff you
know Karl took a soul pill to the chest
trying to get it to it yes like this
weekend
no not ideal for me you booked the
ticket oh we're gonna rip his head off
well break the face off or something
okay no that was just um that was a TV
I'm watching some mad money and you know
how crazy that guy can get hey guys we
got a change of plans
Jarvis punch man I gotta soak this
bovine down yeah come on ders don't just
stand there we got a jerk this beef man
Adam yeah look guys my dad's visiting
tomorrow
Oh
can I borrow one of your towels you're
already using my towel all of your
towels were my towels
you